one last welcome back to the general
podcast the final episode of 2017 she
was kind of crazy spies in Ireland
feel all different in 2018 because we're
gonna be the same exact room with the
same of that camera I think Mike's 2018
be crazy different I can't even tell you
because next month means there's a new
collection of me and he's dropping you
can get your immunities right [ __ ]
now
so you got a Mia nice calm slasher and
you get 20% off okay
it's an exclusive deal just for you all
right
holiday socks holiday underwear three
times softer than cotton right to your
front door guys what's the one gift you
give but you never want its undies okay
so now you want to give think you have
that backwards you give but you never so
you always get you never wanted one gift
you get but you but you never want
growing up right I got socks
that's sucked I got underwear that's
sucked but me and these changes at all
okay it flips it on its head now it's
like cool to get those those gifts so
you might as well spread that love
around your family they're gonna be like
what you got me underwear them you're a
touch it they were like wow you're my
favorite person in this room now and
it's gonna get real awkward because
they're gonna fight with other people
also guys live to sponsor the podcast
guys the holiday season is expensive
okay you can start driving for lyft on
your time right now you make your own
hours you flip into driver mode and
they're looking for drivers right now
okay so you know lyft comments ly ft.com
slash annejulien
you sign up be a new driver for lyft
it's a great awesome gig to get going
like I said you make your own hours is
really great and you get a new $500 new
driver bonus when you sign up using that
URL or click the link and link in the
description be low
thank you sponsors the sponsors
I am the sponsor yes peligro yo soy so
you really want to learn how to do that
effect not even correct Spanish the high
the blast like the blasted speakers
effect yeah cuz you just have a saw the
video yeah I love that
well wait the last podcast we were here
right oh yeah we did the Scott one and
the meat of the tree cast it's crazy man
it's crazy to think that next time we're
here recording it's you know it's not
gonna be the holiday season's gonna be
the new year I don't know every year it
feels like that but it's where are we
going on year three with this thing I
don't know I think so sure we don't even
know I think we were like 140 episodes
52 weeks in a year yeah that's crazy
yeah I mean we take some weeks off yeah
but yeah which means we're past year
three then I don't know maths quick
maths but man it's it's really cool it's
exciting we so we figured for this
episode we could just kind of sit and
recap the year but on a personal level
well we divided into categories the
categories are as follows we had
personal things that we're gonna reflect
on because I mean one thing that I think
a lot of us can agree on is that a lot
of 2017 was allowable dumps defy it it
was but it was the dumps to file a lot
of [ __ ] not cool things happened in
2017 and I don't think we're gonna be
recapping a lot of that because you can
find that just about everywhere on the
but we're gonna recap like our favorite
stuff of the air so we have personal
stuff youtubers memes podcast episodes
and songs yes it's good I say we start
with end with a personal stuff let's
start the other stuff first
OAH Keys playing I Scott hey Scott how's
it going lag daddy alright which one
you're gonna start I think we should
start with podcasts
I guess that's yeah
favorite podcast of 2017 alright also
guys if you want to tweet us I'm judging
the podcast or on our main accounts like
some of your favorite moments of this
year like feel free to do that because I
honestly love when you guys do that
because you see things from a completely
different perspective than we do right
you know but you're in the same world
you're seeing all the content we're
being a part of and so feel free to join
this party right now so to speak and
tweet you know your favorites at us if
we miss any or whatever alright you're
if they go with the podcast you start
okay I had pizza party which was
actually funny because like that night I
forget what was going on but like we are
completely exhausted
we're also like completely out of ideas
for the podcast at that moment yeah like
I know you guys know this but like you
know for however long I've been doing
YouTube and the podcast and they were my
radio show every week like the live
stream I feel like our Twitter's like a
lot easier because I sort of just
they're hanging out but a lot of the
rest of what I do for the week is like
constantly coming up with things which
gets so completely draining and
exhausting and that was just one of
those weeks where we were just like I
got nothing of value right now what do
you say we sit down and order some
pizzas and have a pizza party on the
podcast and do like pin the tail on the
donkey and like cut hide-and-seek yeah
so like a lot of the podcasts I feel
like was we didn't know if it was gonna
work what was it was it happen and a lot
of podcasts are like that yeah yeah come
up with an idea for something but you
know we can't really be sure if it's
even gonna be fun or funny if you guys
are gonna like it if it's gonna be
entertaining if we're gonna like it but
pizza party
just the purest form of fun that I think
we've had on the podcast so I'm like
it's maybe not the greatest podcast
episode ever experience of doing it like
for us anything for people to watch us
basically play - see the podcast like
that moment of you hunched behind me
gargoyle absolutely maybe not my top of
the year but puts that podcast on the
top of the air yeah I mean you have to
remember and it's kind of a hard thing
to think about when you're watching or
listening to a podcast is that it's just
like a video it's just like any other
creation and we're stems from an idea
and has to be developed and they're a
full thing like these podcasts are
anywhere from like I don't know 35 40
minutes to an hour hour 10 minutes and
that's a lot of time to fill and so a
lot of times it might seem like we're
just on here doing whatever but it does
take creatively a lot of energy and you
know crap energy and prep in a out of
the tree and out of the brain space
that's already giving out that energy
press for other things like you learn
myself that's that was a fun one it was
really fun
like I didn't think it was gonna be that
fun yes I was like coming up with what
games we could play and like a sack cups
let's play pin the tail on the donkey
and he wrote the sponsors on the
cardboard my best work I think like just
that clip I could watch over and over
again with me being like okay where are
you and I was like scream laughing yes
I'll do mine I have to go back for the
car cast oh we did too this year well
yeah I don't remember when the first one
yeah so we the most recent one we went
to get doughnuts and we were like let's
just do a car cast for we driving get
doughnuts and I don't know it's it was
it was a fun experience I think a
because we got doughnuts any time you
get [ __ ] doughnuts life is goddamn
good and it's gonna be ingrained in your
memory that that was a good night but I
think it was cool because we I don't
know I remember that we got there we
were halfway through the podcast because
we like braked we were like okay we're
gonna break go get our doughnuts come
back and start up again and they were so
nice to us in there they like comped our
doughnuts for no reason
and then we got back and we were just
kind of eating there and like I remember
there was a moment where I was just like
sitting there eating my doughnut with my
mic you know talking to you and like
there's a camera there and I was just
like so thankful that it was like that's
what we got to do that night and as like
a part of our job and I think that was
like a really cool fun way of like
taking the podcast and making it a new
format just because we felt like it that
week and it turned out to be like a very
cool like life experience type of fun I
agree I feel like we did a couple of
things with the podcast this year that
allowed us to play with the format at
least physically like having a mobile
hey you can just say move closer to the
mic instead of going like this we're
gonna help you go ahead i julienne some
meat I have a disease or I have to touch
a microphone it's when you're like
talking back here I can't hear you you
can't hear me I'm just trying to help I
think it's cool that we played with like
the static nough some and you know even
if sometimes we were like what if we
just podcast it in the car like first of
all it was a magnificent feat for you to
like make the car able to podcast and
like the way you taped off everything
everywhere yeah it took it wasn't just
like let's go hop in the car and throw
the camera in there like you really it's
hard to rig a car
yeah you candid that thing out and even
while we did the couch cast and the
Christmas tree like yeah maybe they're
not like the arc best podcast subject
matter wise or any other way but like
I'm proud of us for trying different
things and at least like like I look up
to rhett and Link a lot love them a lot
of the internet looks up to them and
loves them as well yeah like they they
really do a lot for the podcast format
in terms of online and what what is it
cuz they're breaking the rules because
there really are no rules if you think
about it though yeah yeah I think I
think that's a good aspect of the cast I
mean we don't we don't have editing or
like a show format like they do
sometimes but I think there's really
cool watching them you know transform
their podcasts into something that's so
different and you know maybe we're doing
it in slow little baby steps but I'm
proud of us for you know trying
different things and
not just letting him be exactly the same
all the time yeah yeah it's cool and for
some reason like again we never it's
just the Internet like we never know
what people are gonna like if you post
things on the Internet you never gonna
know what people like or don't like you
you know throw stuff out there yeah you
guys liked that stuff so it was it was
cool and it was encouraging so yeah and
I think that like 50% of that goes to me
and 50% of that goes to you like the
credit of us doing that because uh
sometimes you're you have an idea and
I'm just like okay and then sometimes
I'll have an idea and you're just like
down right and like if we weren't down
for those kind of out-of-the-box moments
we wouldn't have those right so like
pizza party like I love how that
happened
and I love how carcast happened like we
couldn't [ __ ] think of an idea
podcast and we really want a donut so I
was like what if we just [ __ ] you're
doing it every week you're like on top
of everything else that you do every
week and it's a lot you know so you're
like [ __ ] man I just kind of keep it
real right now let's go get some [ __ ]
done yeah like being real like at the
it's the end of the year mm-hmm and we
get two weeks off we're gonna see you in
January we're gonna take Christmas and
New Year's off but going into this break
and going into the next year like I
don't feel like oh another year we have
to do the podcast I feel like just as
excited as I ever have been about the
podcast because of seeing how we've been
able to sustainably continue it like
we've made decisions to where we're
happy each week as much as it's like a
job and and you know it takes work we're
not feeling like exhausted by it
creatively or otherwise absolutely and I
think it's a cool thing that we're
ending the year and I'm feeling like
like excited to go internationally
agreed 100% um what else was one of your
era is in my turn your turn
2017 gone it's a really good run like
that of iconic that was a that was
another thing inspired by all of you
lovely people that comment you guys
Davers content yeah but it was you know
universally something that was taking
over the Internet and so we just we just
consolidated
50 minute but it admit it honestly makes
for a great game it is a great game and
it's kind of turned into like a running
game like in the twitch chat oh yeah
and even like when we're doing podcasts
it's like I don't know I'll have to go
back and look like when we started doing
this like writing things and in cups and
making things go together yeah it's it
like just provides endless hours of fun
like if you're if you're [ __ ] camping
or like doing something you're not using
your phone and you're just hanging out
and having fun it's so outrageously fun
yeah
the roulette style of kind of podcasters
yeah I don't think I put it on here but
I absolutely loved the presidential
roulette one that we made because I
thought that was so [ __ ] funny about
Gary Johnson being the president over
and over and over and now we do
presidential roulette BAM roulette
clickbait roulette yeah headline
roulette like there were a lot of them
they were all really [ __ ] from yeah
but I think 2017 comments really came
like those were made for that kind of
format because you could just throw
anything together that's violent or
inappropriate and it really does make a
great 2017 Cup yeah yeah that's true
manually rewind my [ __ ] like a VHS tape
oh my god what else you got let's see I
think I haven't seen one do I just uh
snake way off yeah mine too yeah that's
funny but that was another thing we like
didn't know if that was gonna be weird I
was kind of worried that wasn't gonna be
a good podcast yeah because like was it
too meta right like you know I do this
egg ways for fun to make the sponsors
enjoyable for you guys and it's kind of
a meme at this point but I was afraid
that not only was it this podcast gonna
take away from that but it was gonna
like kind of just make for a weird yeah
it caught it totally weird but the fact
that like you were you're so proud of
yourself we were saying and I couldn't
hold it in and I was just like dying
laughing and also like honestly having a
taste of my own medicine
on the real like having you do it to me
yeah it was really funny kind of like
hey
now the podcast works I feel like in
2018 that's something that I would
return to segue off yeah it's a definite
like we can definitely do a part two for
that yeah and even snake oil I've seen a
lot of people request that we play again
yeah that was a hostage that was fun
think about those like those ones it's
like when you're in a like a [ __ ]
mood yeah and you're like excited and
those those ones are the best
yeah oh good snake oh it was good it
looks like a couple of our you had Scott
and so is John I saw my other two I had
esto but also Scott but I had I thought
for some reason I had to keep it short
but yeah I mean there's s there was such
a sweet kid this story of how he got on
the podcast and how he was on the
podcast and it was just all said it's so
cool to me yeah I feel like that was
such a cool moment in like you know we
found his videos on my channel
and everyone was like I I thought it was
so funny when he made a video and his
mom made a video and everyone was
tweeting at them at me being like he
made another video I'm like I know found
him on the in myself but I actually was
really cool and it was such like a a
really fun internet moment for me you
know to find someone that you really
enjoy and then to have a chance to talk
to them it's like when does that get to
happen never literally never know I was
like a very cool thing like a lot of
times you have to wait years to go
[ __ ] meet somebody or have a
conversation with them if you've been a
fan of theirs on the internet you know
us included all the time like just
because we're in the community doesn't
mean sometimes we get to meet or talk to
somebody ever you know so I was like it
was really really really cool it was
like a true internet moment was drawn
out of him it was nice on the podcast
there's really just the [ __ ] sweetest
me yeah well that's kind of it and then
Scott it's got yeah that was awesome but
it was really proud I was
I was proud of the Scott way and that
was cool he's the big deal so I mean we
I guess in 2017 we didn't really have a
ton of guests which I'm okay with
I am too and I would like you to answer
in the comments below how you feel about
that
well two because I feel like and this is
no shade to anybody ever but I feel like
a lot of other podcasts is just always
you know a new guest all the time and
you know sometimes I just feel like
that's not what we want all the time or
what you guys want all the time it would
take up a lot of time to make sure we
were booked with a guest every single
week and maybe it's nice to just listen
to a podcast or just [ __ ] show [ __ ] I
agree
yeah I agree and logistics aside of
having a book guests on a weekly basis
that's tough but aside from the
logistics of having to do that
we created this podcast for the exact
reason of what we do yeah and three
years later now we're doing the same
thing as we were at that coffee table
with those USB mics on the laptops like
we were this is what we wanted to do
just talk about [ __ ] and play stupid
games and maybe drink sometimes have our
kind of dialogue be shared with you and
I think it's cool that like our podcast
revolves around that and the occasional
guest will make it special but we that's
not our bread and butter yeah I agree
yeah I think that I think it's cool and
they're like again like you said there's
nothing wrong with podcasts that that
circle around each episode have you knew
yes that's traditionally what a podcast
is right but I think it's cool how we've
done it and stayed kind of true to it
yeah I like it
it makes it like more gentle Julianne
podcast totally yeah well Plus also I
feel like we do our podcasts out of our
house so anytime someone's on the
podcast you have to smash them into this
little room and like you know get them
past the barking song etc so there's
like there's a level of professionalism
to having a guest that I'm not sure what
quite at carefully we fit Elijah and
Christine on this [ __ ] desk I can't
believe it what a feat of a wide lens I
[ __ ] stretch the green screen and
move the table back it's hard though
it's hard to have more than one guest
and even when we do have a guest it's
like the person sitting in the middle
sort of like talking yes like this you
know like eventually I think someday
we're gonna play with the physical
format but you know we rent our house is
that we've done along in this
and we'll keep this until we move out of
here someday but like I'm not opposed to
making it more comfortable to be able to
have guests on down the road yeah I
agree I think that's a goal of both of
ours yeah I think you should have gone
back on the podcast and tell her to come
over like on a Saturday and just not be
home what is wrong with you like not be
home
we just leave us turn off always except
when she pulls into the driveway we shut
the gate
so she's stuck then can't leave with you
where do you want me to start I have a
couple categories of what's wrong with
me not going it is going okay yeah if
you have it all zoomed in and it goes
lagging and it was freaking out all
right so next we have youtubers songs
and memes
let's do late stuff what's your song
let's see songs what are your favorite
songs 2017 I feel like my favorite songs
are everyone's favorite songs I just
think to really obscure someone really
obscure well one sort of obscure song
and one really sad song okay the obscure
sort of is everything now yes very
obscure it was trending it's a big song
but I like it it's not like on top 40
all the time it's yeah I like that song
love that song I like that song and then
too good at goodbyes was something that
really got to me this year love that so
like it and Jenna hates that I like it
because it's like what emo time and I'm
like turning out she's like no no yeah
no Julian's definitely guilty of like
they're all have friends over or like
having a drink or like some time when
everybody's just trying to kick it and
remember when we first met and like
Pink's try was sort of like big on the
radio or maybe not like right when we
first but so we'd be like drinking and
hanging out he's like I got it Seungyeon
it's like did it did it did it and it's
good and I'm like dude I know I'm gonna
turn up to this right now I do
whoa low-key downer you know you've not
probably turned up until you've turned
up to pinks try god I did huh okay take
a shot
no it just makes really a sad night man
like if you're at a party and all of a
sudden someone Yanks the Ox croquette
I'm not I'm not literally turning up to
it it's like I don't know I don't know
just sue me okay I like that song no
it's it's it's not that you like the
song it's like when you play it at times
when I'm like dude come on I just I just
have moments when I'm drinking where I
get maybe a little emotional when I'm
like okay I want to hear something
that's tapping into that okay but when
that's how it came out it Julian was
sitting in the office I was like
upstairs in the shower or something and
I come down and he's just sitting there
like this and his computer chair babe
are you okay
are you all right yeah it's all just
it's so good what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you like but Sam Smith could just sing
about like a potato and I'd make it my
ringtone I don't even need to relate to
the lyrics yeah like it's just it's a
great song yeah I feel you um what are
you my son yeah number one easily don't
hate me for saying this but despedido it
like not only broke records on YouTube
but like so I do my radio show once a
week on Sirius XM and that was trending
and if there's anything I learned from
2016 20 15 2014 whatever yeah the
biggest songs of the year on YouTube are
almost always with the exception of kpop
occasionally almost always in Spanish
spanish-speaking songs videos they get
like triple the views that yes yeah like
insane views and when I heard that song
when it was first training on my show
you know do my research I watch the
video you know look up about the person
and whoever yeah I recognize daddy
yankee so I was like laughing a little
to myself like oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] is 2017
I got a song about daddy yankee on my
show hell yeah
and like the first time that I heard it
I was like this could have come out 10
years ago or 10 years from now yeah and
it would just be a [ __ ] good song and
it's a great [ __ ] song yeah
yeah the videos cute and adorable and
I've heard the lyrics herb and that was
before the beaver verse totally yeah you
were on that song before it blew up to
the point because we just play
whatever's trending yeah and so that
weekend Brett came over and I sat down
we like you know usually when Brett
comes over he's like you got any good
music as he works at Apple now he used
to work at amp radio with you and so we
are always like trading songs and stuff
that we are like whatever yeah we're
sharing what we found yeah so I played
him des prés IDO and he felt the same
way he was like this is [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] dump and then come you know year
later the most viewed video on YouTube
of all time 22 weight 4.2 4.3 billion I
don't even know anymore
what the [ __ ] so I mean I feel like I
can argue that it's one of the biggest
songs that you're one of my favorite
songs of the year and I just thought it
was cool you know I am I'm not
completely sick of it I'm not either and
the story behind it is very cool like
for you at least I like it a lot of cool
I also had stay by Zedd and Alessia Cara
a hundred million how many times a
hundred million before like and I love
that song but like you played it so much
on your phone before he was even on the
radio and then was on the radio cause I
heard this one hundred million times you
love that song I was gonna I knew your
input on your list something about the
way they [ __ ] put those chords
together man it just like hit you in
this like soul place I [ __ ] it oh my
god I can't
yeah unless you had a big year
absolutely isn't she is she nominated
for a Grammy I don't know I know her
song with logic is nominated for best
video else but I can't remember would
not surprise me at all forgive me yeah
um can you look it up yeah yeah yeah for
sure um I also thought it was so
hysterical when BTS did a red carpet
interview with Chelsea who works a lot
of VidCon and stuff but I forget what a
word show maybe American Music Awards
and she was like what American artists
would you or what artists would you guys
all want to work with in the future and
they all just were like said totally
said like they were fangirling over
zedd yeah so she's a nominee for Best
New Artist song the best music video and
best pop duo first a soul it dude
Alessia Cara I know he'll did this year
that's insane I know shouts out to
Alessia she's a dink fan but I just
thought it was so cute that all of ETS
was like you know there's there's no
like Kanye there's no Lady Gaga or it's
just said we all want is so bad [ __ ]
dope and you appreciate dope music and
good for you you guys are [ __ ] great
and adorable and delightful I also had
chasing highs by Alma oh that's such a
good one I should have put that one that
was such a good song such a good song I
was Jason path yeah that was like
another one that we just played
relentlessly yeah
if you have not seen that video I cannot
recommend it enough
if you watch that video and like are not
in love with her at the end of that get
[ __ ] you're lying to yourself she's
the [ __ ] dopest check in the whole
world yeah and I love her voice and I
love that song that video the video was
cool it was shot in old Vegas I was shot
very like very I don't want to say like
DIY because it's such a high quality
video but the way they shot the the
different vignettes they had and this
yeah he says it looked like they just
they were like there when no one was
there yeah it was really cool
her hair her style like I just I love
her bright yellow Julianne hair yeah I
love her obsessed with her Alma Alma
Tarzan boy song that came on like 1987
or some [ __ ] it's just having some
twitch like we starting dinner song yeah
I also for my last song cuz I was trying
to keep it condensed okay don't get mad
at me lemon any ardian Rihanna hmm
amazing sounds good amazing sounds good
it's such I got absolute [ __ ] you to the
pop forum that's been going on for a
long time and and please don't come for
me in the comments for all you doing a
wonderful job being commercial where any
big hats and making very commercial
pop music but it was [ __ ] amazing to
like as someone that loved any Rd to
hear them make music again like that
with that actual edge and not just give
me that [ __ ] hard [ __ ] or get out I
agree Briana's rap verse on there was
fantastic
yeah and she could literally make a ten
minute long song of her farting I would
be like yeah the dopest [ __ ] I've ever
heard
but it was fantastic is that something
that you want but it would have be
accompanied by a video of her farting -
fine I don't care as long as she's
wearing me and using the video I'm sorry
thank you and thank you to Jenna to my
wonderful partner here for setting me up
with that awesome Segway guys holidays
are here me and ease Rihanna farting
guys holidays are here guys and you're
welcome Mandy's for that idea because I
know now you're gonna write that in a
pitch jacket Center to Rihanna's people
and maybe if that happens I will have
done something good right now but until
I do something good let me just tell you
a little bit about me and ease because
they are the softest underwear you will
ever wear it's three times softer than
cotton it doesn't make sense on paper
but when you put them on your butt it
makes sense and it all clicks and all of
a sudden you love underwear again okay
it feels like a ring nothing but a
little bit better it's amazing okay
brand-new designs each month they work
with some of the hottest artists around
they're dope people they sponsor the
twitch stream okay they have socks they
have bra let's they have lingerie for
women and men
ladies ladies and men tell me where the
men are they are guys I can't even I
can't even tell you it's the gift that
keeps on giving I have my drawer is
literally overflowing with me undies
upstairs I don't know what to do about
it I don't know what to do about I don't
want to throw them out they're still in
great quality because I have them from
like months and months and months and
months ago but I keep getting new ones
because I got the subscription service
which I love
because there's new designs it's
stressful me undies are stressful how
good it is ok go to meet undies dot-com
/ Jun is doing right now that's me on
these emmys.com / Jun and Julian you get
20% off free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed guys I can't
even tell you how great they are
they're not like I can't even tell you
okay I'm gonna need to go take a little
ride right now if I were to choose a
ride I know they're looking for drivers
that's my necklace
I just hit my next level I've reached my
final form segue into another sponsor
from another sponsor guys lift is
awesome ok 9 out of 10 drop lift rides
get a perfect five star rating okay it's
the ride-sharing service that the
company treats their drivers right okay
you get tips when you drive people you
keep a hundred cent of the tips you cash
out instantly with Express pay you don't
have to wait weeks to get paid that's
great the tips add up over two hundred
million has dollars have been made by
drivers since the tipping feature was
introduced when I get a nice lift ride I
have a key conversation he driving
pretty far
she drives it pretty far whatever I get
out I'm like you know what the tip thing
pops up and I'm like yes why didn't this
always exist this is so great you tip
your bartender why don't you check tip
your driver that could be you right now
okay earning that money on your hours a
great company overall okay right right
now go to lift comets ly ft.com / Jenna
Julian and you get a $500 new driver
bonus okay and then you get an awesome
new activity to make money doing it's
really great okay thank you to lift
thank you to me undies for this episode
and for the whole entire year of being
amazing podcast sponsors and that goes
for all of our sponsors really really
appreciate the support
yeah thank you guys speaking of sponsors
let's get back to the podcast that
wasn't no you're gonna segue I wasn't
anything else I got very concerned were
you gonna leave yeah alright let's see
the next one you do not not it's okay
another thing we do means okay memes
games then we'll do youtubers then we'll
do personal my favorite meme is under
the desk I know Julian what show then
what I like the blinking guy meme and I
like that okay I know I like a lot more
but I couldn't think of I don't know how
to I could barely think of any but if
you you realize the whole point of this
is that you're supposed to punch the
person out yeah I grew up in and went to
school also well then why don't you ever
do it doesn't my gonna punch you
I'll punch Collin I got him a bunch of
times and funny it's you just get the
satisfaction of someone looking at ya
because they feel stupid and you got a
key below your waist I went to I air
dropped a picture of my hand to Colin
and he looked at it got I just
appreciate you know 2017
dumpster fires a year it was it also
made it so this is a fun game it's like
a possible 2017 version you can use tech
with you can here drop things you can do
the open for a surprise version I loved
I loved at all it's just all great all
right
how youtubers do you have other memes
did you care about my music I'm sorry
you said you couldn't find any means I
didn't know you had baby so what I said
all about rewind the tape the spongebob
typing sounds [ __ ] good like this is
such a dumb meme and then you see like
someone typed things out like that it
really makes me laugh it's really funny
um first of all because it's so petty I
love all the pettiness of the memes this
yeah all of whom are petty I love it I
love the first so worst of all is good
because of that one [ __ ] tweet that
was notable you're not my dad you can't
keep quoting vines from three years ago
and expect people know what you're
talking about and the person wrote first
of all you're not my dad
I'm so excited I hope I hope you to is
something cool my my last name is just
all vines like ones they're not dead to
me they're more powerful than ever
well what's interesting to me is like
this year I've seen more and more vine
threads of like the obscure [ __ ] that we
used to watch than I ever saw when
Vipers around which is crazy but it's
cool because it makes me feel like the
memes that we love so much from buying
are not dead yeah they're still alive
they're still kicking it's also so
impressive to see them continue to have
a lifespan on YouTube or compilations
where yeah just people are still
laughing still enjoying them yeah like
they're the vine content is aging some
of it is aging relatively well like good
wine yeah like they're still funny yeah
right you have youtubers your favorite
youtubers of 2017 binging with babish
okay relax
Goffin that's my only really large like
large scale youtuber that I picked for
this list and I know how how much he's
grown and he's like hugely popular now
but I will say I you know I saw I found
out about him early this year and it's
just cool it's cool to see a channel pop
up that's doing something that that is
being done in a creative new way with us
with a certain style that you haven't
seen before and I think one of the
reasons Andrew succeeds at his channel
that's his name andrew is because he has
so many different elements that are
working in one place it's not just
cooking it's not just food from TV and
movies it's not just cinematography and
it's not just good voiceover it's all of
it every single Vinny's funny and he's
funny and I think that combo is like
such a deadly combo it's like so good
he's got all these aspects working for
him on a visual level audio level you
know you connect with him there's
there's a nostalgia of these days he's
entertaining really really great channel
like one of my favorites I've ever found
probably my favorite this year don't
look at my list I look at what I need to
look at
I have some all used you have one that's
it no I have three others oh one two
four others I have some like old school
oh gee youtubers that I feel like have
had an incredible resurgence for me
personally yeah one of which is Shane
Dawson like I love the way that Shane
has reinvented himself yet again and I'm
really enjoying what he's making and it
seems like he is - which is like doubly
enjoyable you know when you can tell
that someone's soul in life isn't being
sucked out of them yeah in that they're
succeeding in doing what they want yeah
I I'm proud of Shane and I think that
what he's doing is really really cool
and I've enjoyed his content in 2017 a
lot podcast I agree if now if he can
only get his ass on our podcast again
and we miss you Shane but for real his
podcast like every single time we drive
somewhere road trips all we do is always
what Shane imprints always yeah that's a
great [ __ ] show yeah no but it is
cool the point the point of like a
youtuber that you liked or used to like
and still liked but you see them go
through kind of a metamorphosis and it
works for them and they're happy you're
like it's a cool thing to watch
I just think it's cool because I've
always enjoyed chain and to like to grow
with him and you know I mean we're
friends personally but like when you
like someone's content when you're 13
and then you know they've grown up and
you've grown up and you can still find a
way to like them when you're a little
older they just think it's rad you know
so I like your company yeah he's a he's
an adult and he's doing stuff that he
wants to and and I find it entertaining
cuz I'm also an adult but I would maybe
if I was 13 okay I knew it doesn't
matter just it's like it's amazing to me
that when someone is talented and
entertaining and they're you know going
through that I still I still like you no
matter what you're doing and but I do I
think he's doing a fantastic job yeah um
also along those lines speaking of
reinventing yourself
Trisha [ __ ] penis had an
amazing 2017 III pretty sure I've said
this on this podcast before but I feel
like I could write a dissertation about
Trisha Paytas and why I think she's
[ __ ] brilliant
and incredible and you know a lot of
people didn't like her for the longest
time because they didn't understand what
she was doing or like that's best for
all that people who she is but she's
gone through these waves I feel like of
trawling super hard and then not
trolling and being herself and people
are you know mean to her as a person or
like not understanding but like I feel
like she's gone full-blown like even
less Fox which I didn't know is even
possible yeah and I feel like people are
starting to actually appreciate her
which has been really wonderful to see
you know what I mean like the I love you
Jesus is the block of the century it's
about when we plank custom games on
Twitch and someone's playing that song
or they like type it in so it reads in
that voice like the other one time I
overdose but I wasn't lifted by the
ambulance but by the Holy Ghost it makes
me laugh every time yeah and you know
regardless of whether or not she says
it's serious or any I don't care
it is outrageously entertaining I find
her to be one of the most entertaining
people ever yeah there is I don't care
whether she's trolling not just don't
care I think that she's [ __ ]
brilliant and hysterical and she's one
of the best trolls on the Internet of
all time damn what a Tricia Stan I am a
Trisha soon but I I'm like whatever I
just it I feel like I've also said on
the podcast in the past you guys like
yeah she's super even when she's being
you know a little more real yeah she's
like opening up and talking about things
you know there's always nasty people in
the comments that are just there to say
something real dick to her yeah and it
hurts my heart when people are just
really mean to her for some reason cuz I
feel like she gets a lot of [ __ ]
sometimes but it's been really as a
former and current and future Trisha
Stan it's been really nice to watch
people tweet things to her like this is
[ __ ] dope this made me laugh well
people like you said people are starting
to pick up on like what she's actually
been doing yeah that's smart and it's
not stupid but even when she's being
like outrageously transparent and open
you know we're talking about you know
her time as an escort whatever people
will always trying to reason through
real [ __ ] angry at her and
bothers me in the Internet man leave
Trisha alone
I think we're saying I did not think you
were gonna pick her but like I am NOT
surprised also like every time she posts
and she's like she posted looking the
other day that was like I don't identify
as a person anymore cuz you just got a
plastic back then she was like I don't
care I don't care what it is it's
amazing I don't care what you do it's
[ __ ] fantastic and I'm here for it
and as long as you're okay as a person
for the most part do whatever you want
on the Internet I'm here to watch it I
think you're fantastic entertainer turn
here yet who else did you have dear
someone Oh true dear someone I didn't
even think of that a guy named John runs
that channel it's a highlight channel
primarily of pub G highlights
edited down to a bite-sized ten or
eleven minute video but he's kind of
he's made this whole new style that you
know it's like highlight videos have
always had a relatively known formula
right good music cool moments highs lows
funny whatever but he's done it in such
a way that like for video games at least
I've never seen it done like that yeah
and I think he's brought the pub G
community closer together by doing what
he does yeah and I think that's a
special thing especially when the game
has blown up so big to keep it such a
cool fun community and when you when
you've when you get a crazy play it's
now a D or someone play right it's like
it's like the Kleenex effect right
you're not saying tissue you're saying
Kleenex it's like that's the highlight
reel name now it's like the the world
star of the world world star at a bar
fight hit a head shot across the map is
that yeah
so I think I think he's done a really
great job and I'm excited to see what he
does now that you know I don't expect
his videos to completely change but I am
excited to see how he implements the
replay feature in his videos yeah and
also shouts out for featuring me a
couple times appreciated dog hell yeah
yeah
three of my favorite newer youtubers are
Christine
Nygard and susie from nail career
education she's wonderful by the way
right Susie is wonderful I was watching
her videos I watched the whole entire
thing it was like 20 minutes long I was
like this is wonderful is it so relaxing
to watch her she's got a really calming
voice she's well-spoken and it's great
production value 3 camera angles amazing
production perfect audio yeah yeah I
could watch that stuff all day I just
find it so entertaining and relaxing
like even if you were in toenails it's
it's like throwing on a [ __ ] was a
person I'm thinking of to me like
watching nail career education is like
I'm at a spa and it's just like the
blowing sounds of a river or like some
birds chirping but it's Susie and she's
doing some acrylic there enough
it's so [ __ ] relaxing um Christine
from simply illogical absolutely adore
her
I think she's [ __ ] fantastic she
knows that everyone knows that I love
her and it also loves sofia Nygaard and
I feel like between the two of them I'm
just really like more oh my god stop it
a little slightly more time with
Christine
I don't know Sophia as well but um I'm
I'm so like I'm impressed I'm like happy
and excited about something like pretty
Miche as Christine being you know
over-the-top head over heels in love
with nail polish but it's like the more
specific it is the more into it we are
you know I mean I am speaking for myself
no I get that it's not make sense when
she's just sitting in her [ __ ] room
doing a hundred coats of nail polish
it's just like her passion for nails and
nail polish and being excited about
things and being excited about hollows
like it makes you it's so like
contagious yeah yeah I get that pressure
and it's just so cool to watch someone
with an itch passion you invest everyone
else's that you know it's because it's
like I don't even have to particularly
not like nails
in order to be completely entertained by
what you're doing yeah and Christine is
a funny and amazing person outside of
that but I mean that's what sort of
grabbed everyone and it's just it's I'm
excited to see what she does in the
future yeah you know and I hope that she
doesn't feel like she needs to be in the
box of nails forever
yeah like because she's a wonderful
entertaining person she can she can get
outside that box in town she wants she's
gonna succeed even a box she will
literally she's very funny and talented
and she can do a lot of different things
yeah she wants and Sophia Nygaard was
making a lot of content this year that I
just thought was fantastic because it's
not like your traditional YouTube and I
feel like this was a lot of growth for a
lot of people was that you know YouTube
when I started was like your video can't
be over three minutes or else people are
gonna click off it it needs to be really
short and quick and funny into the point
in order to be a video and as it's
turned into 2017 now we're here to like
do whatever we're here for little videos
we're here to spend time yeah I'm cool
for an hour podcast make it [ __ ] 2
hours please like I want to throw it out
in the background and like chill and do
my makeup or you know whatever yeah and
her content to me is something that's so
like I'm genuinely curious like you're
doing the things that that people would
like to do but you know maybe don't have
the time energy effort money whatever to
do yeah and it's not like it's not
overdone she just she does it and I
really I felt like watching her content
has been just a reminder that like you
don't need to do like a ton of crazy
things in order to like have a great
channel which is what's been really
reassuring about the podcast we're like
a lot of stuff that I did on my channel
in 2017 it's like it's a wonderful
reassurance of like I'm here because I'm
interested and excited in you as a
person I'm invested in you as a person
and it's really cool and I I don't know
maybe I'm not wording that no no no it's
it's it's it's nice seeing people
succeed who aren't doing crazy [ __ ] for
view
it's not a gimmick yeah yeah and it's
nice to know that like that is still
something that people value to the point
where people who make content like that
like Christine like Sophia like are
wildly successful
I mean someone a little crazy but it's
like I'm here because you're making
something I'm genuinely interested in
your making it really great that's
that's synonymous with what you've done
like you have started to make channel
like you started turn your channel in
itself it's Jenna time which we talked
about a million times but you started to
be really selfish with your videos doing
exactly what you feel like doing that
week and you've been rewarded by it
because people are so invested in you
and you being genuine and what you
decided to [ __ ] create that week in
whatever format yeah I think having fun
I think I think that's a big reason why
you identify with them it's because
you're a lot like that now I love them I
love question walk yeah you guys have
been promising but yeah it's it's it is
a nice reminder to be like you as
yourself in whatever you're doing is
good enough you know and you don't have
to do anything other than just be here
and whatever you're good enough as you
are you know those were my oh and also
what come on oh wait is this is this you
putting to bed the Ravelry no I just
think objectively he made really great
content yeah dude what you favorited was
wrote me a note and told me to say it
alright the next channel that is good
from 2017 is jacksFilms submitted by
anonymous quality content not quality
dogs that's what it says who the [ __ ]
wrote that no he's at it what fantastic
you're in well deserved like he's gonna
do it might really awesome a [ __ ] this
year
do you wanted to say anything else that
I can relay or are you done you guys
have a big boxing match
we just sit here in silence for the next
10 minutes while she makes that face I
feel the tension does not have to be
real i friends with him one of the
hardest-working most talented people
I've met and been able to watch and
become friends with like a huge example
of what passion in your field can do for
you yeah a little bit you know I like
you know he that she was so massively
talented but it shows you that talent
plus a whole bunch of [ __ ] hard work
and just keeping your head down and
doing it like I still believe he's
underappreciated and I'll probably
forever believe that because you know
his channel is a lot smaller than mine
and I look at his [ __ ] and I'm like you
know you just you are your good man and
I feel like learning from him but
watching his videos talking to him
online but then meeting him and going to
shoot together it's it was an experience
that I value very highly mm-hmm so Matt
chose is definitely up there he's pretty
great
and a little honorable mention to
Lindsey daily she's a ding Pham who has
a channel she does motion graphic work
and I think she does it for a living
but her channel is kind of just a hobby
thing and she's the one who made the new
obstacle animated logo she also made the
last minute trips animation with the
darts hitting the map of all the
locations we've been and I just I think
she's worth mentioning because she had
just tweeted me one of her videos and I
watch a lot of the videos you guys tweet
me all the time whether they're yours or
not but I watch it and it was her making
a loss achill like making a physical
waffle in this a popsicle and I was like
so obsessed with how she did it with the
graphics and it was so clean looking and
it was so unexpected more than anything
that I was like dude like that's [ __ ]
cool and then we then we hired her to do
our animation treatment for the logo and
I think it's just cool the way the
internet works like that because I
literally would have never known about
or her talent until you know she tweeted
that [ __ ] at me so honorable mention to
her that's red
all right now now I wanted to go through
our 2017 proud moments of ourselves
which is sounds really self until
tonight like you're just like oh this is
what I didn't win and I know a lot of
youtubers do that video I look in this
year this is what I did and they have
pictures and music and that's great I
think this is a cooler format of doing
it I think I just wanted to like go
through some of the things that I
remember happening this year that I'm
proud of
I am also kind of proud and not really
ashamed to say that I feel like I had a
good year and I want to just kind of go
through some of the stuff and I want you
to do the same how does that sound
sounds do you go first you go first
doesn't matter can I tell you my top
moment of 2017 personally what is your
top moment getting our son add really
yeah he's such a wonderful boy you know
you love him so much that's like pretty
much my list up kitty well I don't want
to be like I just want to read through
because I like went through my channel
which is so cool it's like a [ __ ]
diary of everything that happened
alright now we indulge myself for a
second real quick
I hit a million subscribers I was
invited to South by to be a guest on the
DJI panel I created wofe Segel I shot
seven episodes of our new original
series and went to eight new places that
I'd never been before I was brought out
to New York City to be a part of the the
release of DG eyes need you're on the
spark which one drone of the year which
is really cool we want a shorty award
come to couch got my wisdom teeth out
released seventeen different collections
of original pins and kind of created a
space for myself in that new merch area
that I always kind of wanted to like
build a brand like that got a hamster
yeah I had one of the coolest birthdays
I can remember which you were
responsible for it was faithful Twitter
tweeted at me we were all arguing about
pulp first no pulp
hmm apparently Twitter is a no pulp
for the first time I made the trending
page and then I made it two times more
and I say that for the first time
because it was like with the UFO video I
made it but this was the first time I've
logged mm-hmm
had made it and then I made two more
times that which was so [ __ ] insane
and surprising did a 24-hour twitch
stream raise over ten thousand dollars
for charity in total between the pins
and the twitch stream I believe maybe
even a little more I met and got to
sponsor a beautiful County and Buttercup
rest in peace I shot my first short film
and I witnessed and documented a total
solar eclipse and the highest path of
totality Julian we are all so proud of
you on behalf of all the ding Sam that
knows and loves you we're all very very
very incredibly proud of you thank you
very much I know you guys are very very
supportive and I see it all the time
it's been a good year we love you I love
you the most though so all y'all can
just [ __ ] off because I love the most
no but like really though you did so
much and it's been an absolute pleasure
to watch you like you know grow up and I
don't mean that in a demeaning way like
to watch you like grow and learn and
like change and you know I don't know I
could say so many things but I'm just
I'm really proud of you and you did have
an incredible year and you have a lot of
reasons to be really proud and really
excited thank you that means a lot
really appreciate it I love you too
alright then we're sappiness your turned
realist dammit
oh [ __ ] who we fight in okay my own
youtube channel I feel like because I've
sort of liberated myself from the making
other people laugh into making myself
laugh which has been a needed transition
and makes me pretty happy and it's
making me happy that people also find
that to be something happy getting back
into any sort of physical capability to
do anything after the car accident it
was a it was a long road I know we
talked about that but I'm I'm really
proud in 2017 the fact that like I can
walk without pain and you know do
physical things in terms of like working
out without pain like I I don't feel
like super great like I definitely feel
like I I took a year and was it unable
to do a whole lot but I feel a lot
better in that you know it's a lot of
work and it's really hard and it's like
a long road but I'm really proud that we
can go like work out now and I don't
feel like I have to stop the twitch
stream I'm incredibly proud of and I
feel like every you know a couple years
or every year so we sort of sit down and
have a powwow about you know what are we
gonna do this year
that's like branching out a little bit
or you know doing something a little
different like what do you want to
change what do you want to keep the same
what are you thinking and the twitch
stream we started a couple years ago and
I'm just I'm really proud of how it's
turned out and you know Pub Judy I think
did a lot for us in terms of wanting to
be live all the time but like I'm really
proud of that community and you know I
think the dank fam started here in the
podcast but there's like almost a whole
other newer community happening on the
twitch stream and it's just it's really
[ __ ] cool to see that like with the
discord and and everything to watch
people interact our mod started dating
there now moving in together for the
first time and there's a couple of other
couples that happened in the the chat
it's just like a really really really
special like sing and I think it's
really like as intimate as you feel
maybe like with your favorite youtuber
or person on the Internet
because I feel the same way there's a
level of intimacy in in like being live
and watching people live that I totally
get and I think is really cool so I'm
excited to continue to do that in 2018
and I'm really proud excuse you
Kermit's car
I'm really proud of what we've turned it
into my nephew was born I'm so proud
that no qualified professional has
touched my hair all of 2017 Wow
and yeah my nephew was born I even
though the year was a dumpster fire no
he's adorable I I second everything
there and I won one last time before
we're in the next year I just want to
say shouts out to you for turning a
channel with an obscene amount of
subscribers and pressure into something
that you were happy with and having it
succeed so well on a weekly basis
hitting the trending page all the time
it's just an incredibly proud thing
because I've seen the metamorphosis and
I don't even if you wanna call that I've
just seen you grow as a person so to
watch that reflect in your content and
then to your content and then back into
yourself and your life it's a it's a
rewarding thing to watch because there's
nothing that you want more than your
significant other your partner to be
happy in what they're doing with their
life and and to be rewarded handsomely
in terms of you know having people
support you through all that is is all
you could ever hope for so one last time
I'm really proud of you and I think it
was a really great crazy good year for
you thank you Jane and I want to also
say thank you I mean you know first of
all thank you for letting us do
different things you know maybe every
podcast isn't gonna be the greatest
podcast revert in your life sometimes
we're trying out new stuff trying out
new formats trying out new ideas maybe
song is gonna be great the same with a
YouTube channel or a vlog or my radio
show or the twitch stream like you got
to just try and try and try and I feel
like you as an audience and as peers as
people that you know have a two-way
conversation with us a lot like I
appreciate your feedback I appreciate
your patience and your willingness to
let us continue to do different things
and express ourselves in different ways
like one thing I've loved about the
Twitter stream is like I'll go to
Julianne be like yo can you let me open
this
tonight sit there do some weird [ __ ]
throw it back on then we'll play some
video games but it's like it's such a
cool way to like I'm gonna sit down and
just do the weirdest [ __ ] thing ever
right now and have a great time yeah I I
just appreciate that you guys continue
to let us take risks and remain
independent and give us the freedom to
do that because I don't I don't I don't
want to be corporately owned I don't I
don't want to answer to anybody like
that's my dream is to be as independent
as possible yeah and I want to thank you
guys for your continued support not only
on my channel Julian's channel the vlogs
this show like it's just it means a lot
to us and this was a great fun year we
had a lot of fun this a lot of fun this
year I second that thank you guys for
everything you guys are the most
important wonderful bunch of people I
ever have encountered on the internet
and I'm so proud to call you my internet
family it really is awesome
you guys are the best pretty fun why are
you growling she's literally walking on
the keyboard over there I'm just like
I'm excited I'm excited for next year
and you know it's just it's been a rough
year world wise a lot of awful shits
happen you know stuff is scary the world
is scary but like I'm I feel really good
the fact that I've like grown up a lot
on the Internet as of you as have we
together and it's comforting that you
know you guys have continued to support
us and like in the future like when our
lives change again and like more older
and stuff I don't know what the future
holds but it at least gives me a little
more confidence to continue moving on
and growing up and going on with our
lives being like you know it's you know
what's the most important thing is just
making sure that you're okay and you're
happy and and keep working on that and
the rest of its whatever but the fact
that you guys have supported us through
that me personally turning into a 31
year old lady that has them
the Hmong in ma I just I really
appreciate it so are you excited I'm
very excited a little time off though to
like I said the beginning of podcast I
can't [ __ ] wait for what's gonna
happen 2018 like the momentum of
everything moving forward it just keeps
me so so happy and ready I'm ready for a
break as well but when we come back I
can't wait to see you guys again here
and elsewhere so thanks for an awesome
year from mr. and mrs. dink to all our
big children yes yes you were still are
doing children guys thank you for an
awesome year and we hope you have a
wonderful break for the holidays guys
take care of yourself treat yourself
enjoy yourself
and we'll see you guys on the internet
this year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you